everybody what's going on welcome to
another python robotics video um
hopefully by now you guys have wired up
all of your motors if you haven't uh
take a second pause it wire them all up
basically you're wiring them up
identically to how you had wired up your
first one where uh since the wheel goes
on this side
black on top right on bottom
like that so my wheels are is still
plugged in this is the original one here
and now we want to just go ahead and
maybe plug in one more wheel but i think
at this point it would be wise to go
ahead and just kind of plug everything
in
and set it up on the frame before we
start doing much programming um
that way we can kind of we can set up
the
the car on like a piece of either you
can use a book or a cardboard box or
something and it just makes makes your
life a lot easier so that's what we're
going to do first so with my frame this
is my frame and this edge of the frame
basically looks like this and again this
was built for this specific purpose
so when you stick the car or the the
motor through like this
uh it's the wheels or the you know the
axle it's gonna fit through the hole
like this and it will hold in place and
then you you put two screws here and
here and that will actually hold the
motor in place depending on what you did
for your frame
you might have to you know i don't know
use some glue or some tape or something
but for anybody who bought the frame
that's all you have to do and then you
stick the wheel on this side so i can
already do that
and now my wheel is in and now what you
actually have to do is
we gotta put screws through it so
actually we don't we want to take out
the wheel so now what we want to do is
screw the motors in place and actually
this one already has the wheel on it so
i'm going to have to take off that wheel
and
this motor is already kind of plugged in
but
now we want to do is actually screw the
motors in so i'm going to do that and
then we'll restart
now for anybody who's actually using the
same frame as me you're going to want to
use these uh the longer screws or screws
right here and then you've got these
little bolts
and you just stick the screw through
here and there's little holes on the
motor so you can actually do this
and that's where how you're going to
keep this motor in place again if you
had some other frame obviously you're
not doing this exact thing
but that's what you do if you bought
this exact frame
so once you have uh your motors screwed
into your frame
we still have this one already you know
plugged into our h bridge um and again
just like like i was mentioning before
they're on the same side so you're going
to plug them into the same slots and you
wouldn't stagger them either because one
wheel wants to turn forwards and one
rear ones to turn backwards
so you're actually going to plug them
into the exact same slots because
you know intuition would tell you if the
motor was facing because i guess you
can't really see but
here like the motors are facing each
other so if they were pointing in the
same direction then you would stagger
in the actual h bridge where they're
plugged in
right we've got the positive lead in out
two the negative leading out one but if
you put
if you did the same or if you did if you
thought you might flip that with this
one you'd be flipping it twice and so
these two motors will work against each
other so actually what we want to do is
we're going to plug the same like the
black this black lead where the other
black lead went in this red lead where
the other red lead went
because we've already flipped
um everything over and we flipped the
motor over so anyway um just pointing
that out for you guys uh so the next
thing that we want to go ahead and do is
we want to start screwing uh our frame
or the rest of our frame together so for
me
this frame uh came with a nice lovely
bottom piece that will screw right into
this one and screw it in this one and
then we can kind of at least have our
car sitting up a little bit
so that's what i'm going to do and if
you have the same frame do that or if
you have your own frame
fit your bottom to it
now once you finish putting the bottom
on your frame the next thing that we're
going to want to go ahead and do is wire
in all of the motors into the age bridge
so to do that
this is the side that's already kind of
wired in for us we've got one of our
motors that is already connected and
that would be this one
so then this one we need to connect so
again you're going to put the black into
the same one so like your black line
should go into out one and your red line
should go into out two
now
on
this side we do need to stagger the
motor so on this side uh if if it's
facing me right well at least we'll out
one is right on the other side of out
four right so out one we've got the
black line but out four we'll actually
want to put the red line so they're kind
of flip-flopped
that way forward is forward for
everybody in reverse is reverse for
everybody so now what i'm going to go
ahead and do is hook all of these up
and then i'll continue on and i'll show
you guys what we've got once that's all
complete
now we'll just mention since both leads
are going into the same spot it can be
beneficial to just take the two leads
stick them together
and twist them
uh together
that way they don't get
like one isn't as likely to come out
when they're both together they're just
a little bit bigger so that clamp holds
them a little bit better when they're
twisted together
all right now once you've got everything
in be sure to give everything a good
good tug make sure you've got everything
in there
good you don't want to rip it out but
give it a good tug and make sure it's
pretty secure in there now that we have
everything
hooked up we don't actually have our
wheels in
and you can either make the decision to
put the wheels in now
and then put this on like a book or a
box something that keeps the wheels off
the ground so it doesn't go running off
on you and ripping cords out of the wall
or something
or you just you can also just not put
the wheels in right because all we have
right now are sticking out is just the
axle basically
but to me it's a little harder to see
which way the axle is spinning as
opposed to if you've got wheels on there
you can tell with your eye much easier
when you put in some code hit enter and
you can see which way the wheel is
spinning now obviously if you just keep
the wheel spinning you know for a long
period of time
you can see which way they're spinning a
lot easier but generally if you're
writing code and you're trying to debug
something you don't want to have to wait
15 seconds per wheel spin that you you
test you just want to kind of make it
spin for a second and then be done
so that's that's kind of how i
see it but depending on which way you
feel obviously you can just leave the
wheels off but if you happen to have
just a box or something just stick it on
the box
so
everything is wired up now so what now
now we want to do is you can kind of
just put things back in here or you can
continue building your frame so if you
have the same frame i have
you've got the edge pieces that look
like this so you can put your edge
pieces on there and just kind of pile
everything in there
put the walls on and put the wheels on
and all that you can leave the top off
for now um so that's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna put the the front and back on
here uh screw those in and then we can
put i'm gonna put my wheels on anyways
and
uh put it on a box and then we'll start
hitting the code so we'll plug it up
plug everything in and go so let me go
ahead and get that done
so now i've got everything together
except for the top on the frame that's
okay
i got all my wheels on good to roll back
and forth so that's good um now uh
we're gonna need to start working on the
code we're gonna have to plug this thing
in
chances are uh unless you've got the
whole edimax thing
um an external power supply you're gonna
have to plug you know your
lan your ethernet into here and also
power supply in there so you'll want to
go ahead and do that at towards the end
is when i'll cover the edimax wi-fi
stuff and you know how to get wi-fi on
the pod it's very simple though if you
don't want to follow along with that you
just stick it in and there's like wi-fi
support right on your desktop just start
x do wi-fi um
it's real simple so anyways uh now what
i want to do is go ahead and plug in the
pi i'm not really going to show myself
doing that i'm going to give it power
give it ethernet and then from there
everything will be
or at least the next step will be
actually writing code and then we'll
test it so anyways i'm going to cut off
the video here and continue on in the
next video with that as always thanks
for watching thanks for all the support
and subscriptions and until next time